get out and travel nevada in a coveted
safe way
well we might have the place for you to
check out in mesquite
take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
mesquite we're open and safe especially
for golf it's the best
thing you can do in this environment
that we're in we have great gaming we
have great dining
all of our facilities our golf
facilities our casinos our restaurants
are ready to have you come out and and
we will
make sure that you're taken care of in
an open and safe matter
and we're ready absolutely ready and we
have nine golf courses
amazing golf courses within really 25
30 miles of mesquite including seven
within mesquite city
including this beautiful facility we are
here today the best in mesquite
conestoga golf club
mesquite is a golf destination it was
built on golf
when when it opened up years ago at the
palms
the golf courses just came casinos and
it's a golf destination because we have
championship golf courses
we have picturesque unbelievable mesa
and vista views
as championship because our golf courses
are quality plus they're challenging
but at the same time too they're
rewarding if you play your shots right
when you get here we have such an
intimate community where you can
dine at our local casino you can game at
a local casino within five minutes you
can be on the tee
or in a casino or at a local restaurant
that's what's so great about
mesquite is we're all a community knit
together to where you can go across
town and be at one golf course or the
other or have dinner within five or ten
minutes
and and that's what we love about it is
we all support each other whether it's
the gaming community the restaurant
community or the golf community
and that's the difference that you're
going to see in mosquitoes we truly all
work together to make sure we give you
that
outstanding experience
you know what we have here mesquite if
you want to come and play and
play multiple golf courses what you need
to do is we have the golf mesquite pass
which is a great local pass that we do
we also have golf mesquite nevada dot
com which is by far
the best place to book your packages
whether you're going to a hotel
or a golf course and it's the lowest you
can get going to golf mesquite nevada
dot com
to get that nice package deal of playing
36 holes a day split
staying at a casino hotel so come out
here
play have a safe time right now at
all of our golf courses we've taken out
the bunker rakes
we've made sure that our cups are are
cut to where you don't have to touch the
flag you can just pick your ball
up we've taken out our coolers we have
make make sure we have gloves and our
mats on when we're
greeting you when you show up so we're
doing all the safety precautions so
it's going to be safe come out we're
open to we're open to play
we're safe so you can hit it long and
straight
the conestoga golf club is located at
1499 falcon ridge parkway in mesquite
nevada
you can give them a call at that phone
number on your screen 702 702-346-4292
or conestoga
golf.com